que faites vous de vos rtt la fameuse
récupération du temps de travail a
hérité des 35 heures
certains se lancent à corps perdu dans
le bricolage d'autres font du sport
daniel wolfromm et jean-louis melun ont
constaté au louvre et à la médiathèque
de poitiers que la culture n'était pas
en reste à poitiers l'endroit le plus
couru de la ville c'est la médiathèque
deux mille visiteurs par jour c'est si
facile disent que livres cassettes tous
emprunte sans effort il est bien tentant
d'y aller quand on dispose de temps
libre est ce que vous êtes aux 35 heures
pouvait tout à fait cheveux 35 heures
vous êtes technicien edf et donc depuis
un an maintenant sommes passés aux 35
heures ce qui permet alors ça me permet
d'avoir mercredi après-midi des ongles
et les enfants à la médiathèque
donc profiter un petit peu de ce temps
libre pour presser avec les enfants je
vous faisais pas avant moi moi moi moi
je sais que je voulais absolument mettre
à profit ces jours là pour faire autre
chose que je ne faisais pas avant sinon
si je dois me contenter de faire le
ménage c'est pas la peine autant aller
travailler
mais c'est évident que le fait d'avoir
davantage de temps permet de fréquenter
certainement les établissements sportifs
ou des établissements culturels comme le
nôtre oui oui bien sûr la preuve c'est
que il faut acheter davantage de
documents parce qu'il faut répondre à la
demande
pas encore de statistiques mais la
direction estime à 10% la hausse de
fréquentation de la médiathèque depuis
l'entrée en vigueur des 35 heures
autre échelle de grandeur le louvre et
ses six millions de visiteurs chaque
année
au détour d'une seule une dame a choisi
son jour le vendredi pour bien profiter
de ces nouveaux moment disponible mois
avant les 35 heures j'avais j'avais une
envie j'avais un manque
j'avais un manque d'aller voir la
peinture à les voir tout ça donc partie
du lot il ya les 35 heures il était
évident qu'une partie de mes 35 heures
ça serait ça bon après je viens une fois
que j'ai vu quelque chose qui me plaît
mois et qui peut plaire à mes enfants à
mon filleul les emmène mais le dimanche
matin là c'est autre chose
là vraiment le le vendredi c'est mon
plaisir c'est mon moment à moi qui m'est
réservé le temps libre est consacré en
général à la maison à la famille ou aux
copains mais peu à peu les activités
culturelles s'impose comme de véritables
évasion